so next up here is alkaptonuria or aku
sometimes it's spelled with a C instead
of a K but I mostly see it with a K
anyway alkaptonuria is an autosomal
recessive deficiency of homogeneous a12
dioxygen a sometimes just called halogen
to say the oxidase and that converts
home agenda say into malleolus Ito
acetate and there are three main things
as far as the features to keep in mind
and I'll point them out in a moment but
before we actually get to that let's
just show how these features are brought
about by the enzyme deficiency so let's
scroll down to take a look at the
reaction right so in the the pathway but
we're going metabolize phenylalanine
tyrosine we have homogeneous a oxidase
turning home legenda sate or home
identity into malleolus II device today
so this is where that block is going to
occur and Homo gentes a will build up
okay and so that causes problems so
let's scroll back up here so the key
thing the most obvious and easy thing
that to note is the accumulation of that
how much and to say and that builds up
in the urine and leads to homo dentist
ik acid urea and one really important
thing about is that it turns brown or
even black upon exposure to the air and
light so that's pretty important noting
the presence of it in the in the urine
especially upon realizing that the urine
turns that dark color like black
basically upon exposure to air in light
and so what can happen is that the
homogeneous a can also accumulate in in
polymerizing in connective tissue
especially in articular cartilage that's
called aqua gnosis okay and when you
have that home those I'm I didn't say
polymers in the connective tissues they
they basically damage the the cartilage
and an inflamed it and they also turned
that the cartilage can also even turn
that dark color alright that brown or
black and so the disc lair of the eye
can be darkened and certain areas of the
skin especially the ear and the nose can
be darkened because those those those
likely during the nose have a lot of
cartilage
okay and this the damaged cartilage can
lead to an early arthritis okay and I
say early and might come up as like
around 30 to 40 or so years years of age
which is pretty early right as far as
far as arthritis goes especially in the
spine hip and knee and it can severely
[ __ ] patients sort of and it sort of
will develop right as overtime the
homogeneous 8 will deposits can build up
so
you